[Music]
okay this is a lightning talk called
code or die we're at PI data Warsaw it's
Friday October 10th to 2017 I'm James
Powell if you like this talk you can
follow me on twitter at don't use this
code this is a talk about a hobby
project that I've been working on over
the past few weeks and as many of you
know hobby projects are a big
distraction in fact one of the best
things about hobby projects is that they
can be very distracting so before I tell
you about coder die I want to tell you
about a couple of things that distracted
me from doing the hobby project that has
been distracting me from doing actual
real work the first one is a library
that I have written called PG SQL parse
most of the things that I'll show you in
this talk are about 50 to 70 percent
done so just wait a little bit before
they're ready to use PG SQL parse is
built on a library called Lib PG Curie
which is an extraction of the query
engine the query the parser from the
from Postgres itself and so what I can
do in Python is I can take string SQL I
can parse it into a Python ast or rather
into a Python representation of the SQL
ast and I do neat things like I can look
at the where clause I can take another
piece of SQL and I can merge them so in
this block of code here I'm taking this
query and I'm sticking it under this
common table expression which is kind of
neat to be able to do in a systematic
fashion now that doesn't seem very
useful so the reason that this was the
lowest level of the Hobby project is
because I needed this in order to do
another hobby project called gormless
and it's kind of a weird name I'll
explain the name to really quickly I
wanted to create a norm for use with
Postgres but I hate ORMs so I wanted to
create like an anti orb and that's low
you could call like PG or malice or in
other words gormless an english gormless
means kind of stupid and this is
essentially a pretty stupid idea what I
have is I have a way to map arbitrary
SQL to the Python object model to Python
methods and python descriptors so here
you can see some base object you can
look up you can look it up by ID by name
and do inserts and deletes here you have
some object it represents a ship you'll
fit you'll see why I call this ship
later and it has some fields like a
speed location there are some looks all
kind of like a uglier version of a
normal
where I have some foreign keys I have
some normal fields that are just
properties and I have some other methods
well the neat thing I can do is I can do
this I can select from the database and
get a Python object out so this thing
ship here is not a tuple it's not
anything else it's an actual raw Python
object and when I have a Python object I
can also do things like ship top by ID
and and pull it out by ID instead of
using a raw query but once I have a
Python object can do things like ship
that location and will give me another
Python object representing the location
of this ship and whatever that might
mean once I can do that I can do neat
things I can say ship location dot
nearby ships to find all the ships that
happen to be nearby that one where this
is a Python property this is a Python
property and it corresponds to a couple
of SQL lookups against my database
itself the interesting thing is I can
then arbitrarily add adapters on top of
that so here ship dot all names is all
the different names that might refer to
this ship notice this is just a property
lookup this gives you a Python
dictionary that has its insert and
removal methods over overwritten so when
I do something like this I do a set item
on the dictionary it actually goes and
updates the database when I do a Dell
item on the dictionary that also
corresponds to a database operation most
ORM s don't give you any of this it only
give you mechanism to interact with the
database via functions not via arbitrary
Python syntax this is an actual Python
dictionary that whenever you perform an
operation on it it transparently updates
a database behind the scenes one neat
thing I can do is if you look closely
here there was this little thing called
notifications well I can start a
separate thread so that if another
process completely separate from mine
updates the object in the database I get
a notification in my Python process and
it transparently updates the database so
this ship object here is always
up-to-date with the current state of the
database or whatever notifications I've
received so I can have multiple scripts
run against this database and I never
have to worry about reloading something
because they're being transparently
reloaded by a thread in the background
that's kind of cool I can also do
something really neat which is I can set
context on my cursor so I can create a
common table expression like this and
then that applies itself using my ast
parser against every operation that
occurs under that context manager so
this ship thought locations out nearby
ships not home world nearby ships is a
bunch of SQL look
each of which is now being wrapped in
this common table expression that's why
it was useful to have that tool so even
this update operation that looks like
just a Ross string is actually being
wrapped in that common table expression
which is very useful for now doing very
complex very very complex lookups
against the database and transforming
them into single SQL statements very
efficient ones I can also create
arbitrary queries so here's the
definition for a query I select some
from and some - from some database here
the parameters I pass it I give it a
graph adapter so that I can now select
things out of my database and turn them
into Network X graphs most ORM s give
you one table row equals one object my
RM is not really an ORM it's just an
arbitrary mapping of SQL to Python the
Python data model so I can take subsets
of tables and turn them into Network X
graphs no other RM can do anything close
to that similarly if I did something
like scores here I can give it an array
adapter and I can select subsets of my
database of subsets of rows in my
database and transparently stick it into
an umpire in the array and when you
update that number numpy in the array it
transparently updates the database
contents itself nobody else can do that
why because who cares right well I came
up with an idea for a game many of you
have played the game risk it looks kind
of like this and I thought what if we
took the game risk and we set it in
space we added spaceship solar systems
neat things like that because we don't
want to be sued for copyright
infringement we make it a real-time game
we take away the game board in the game
pieces entirely and we replaced them
with a JSON API so using a tool HTTP I
could give any arbitrary semi-technical
user this command and they could kind of
figure out what it does
it's an HTTP request I get all the
systems you can probably kind of guess
what that does even if you don't know a
lot about JSON API even if you don't
know a lot about the command line or
about Python you can guess what this
does it gets all the ships you could
guess what this probably does it gets
the system number 32 you could probably
guess what this does it puts an order on
ship number 12 and tells it to move to
some destination it's a very simple very
low-level JSON API what I could do is I
could give players of this game a
will hand out with curl commands and
they could play the game by just
manually writing those curl commands in
the console anyone could play this game
but and what they do is they start with
something as simple like as this that I
wrote for them and they'd start kind of
playing around with the parameters
they'd say Oh
12 to 23 or that moves ship 23 not ship
12 going from this this moves it from
Mars to Venus well interestingly enough
for the first 30 minutes of the game
people could move about 10 ships around
which is manual API calls it would be
really tedious but what if I'm scaled up
the game to a hundred ships then you'd
have to write a bash script so the
newbie will have to come to me and say
well how do i do these commands in a
loop because i can't type these fast
enough to compete in the game and you
tell them well this is how you write a
simple bash script and as they write
more and more complex bash scripts
they'll say this sucks so what are they
gonna do they're gonna write Python
scripts the API output is JSON that
looks something like this you're gonna
get bug eyed if you look at this too
closely and the newbies gonna say I
cannot interpret these results quickly
enough to play the game and you're gonna
tell them well why don't you write a
report using Python here I'll tell you
two about F strings I'll teach you about
the request library I'll teach you about
all the things you need to be
competitive in the game maybe you could
even write a web front-end so I'll teach
you about Django and flask and that
might help you play the game and win
against your friends what happens when
there's hundreds of ships moving in real
time even if you had scripts and a JSON
API even if you had a meta API and
scripts and things like that you won't
be able to compete so what do you have
to do you have to write a bot you have
to use simple AI techniques in order to
compete in the game I like this game
because you start very simple and you
can get arbitrarily complex driven by
the desire of the players to be
competitive at the game even newbies can
play by just copying pasting commands so
their terminal but they will through
natural motivation of wanting to be
competitive in this game come to you and
say how do I get better teach me more
about programming I need to know how to
do this tie this explicit tangible goal
that I have in playing the game to some
arbitrary abstract piece of programming
knowledge it is a very strong motivation
to learn programming and to improve your
programming because the worse your code
is the worse your performance in the
game will be I like this also because
it's an approach to programming via
automation and the in the automation
view perfect
doesn't matter the only thing that
matters in this game it's not perfect
code it's not writing the best code it's
about competing
it's about galactic domination so that's
code or die it's the rules are on github
the other two libraries will be posted
to github but once they're a little bit
closer to complete
I hope to talk about this game more next
year when it's fully developed the API
is going to be very simple and the whole
goal is how do we take somebody who
wants the program but who finds most
materials for programming too simple and
too sorry not too simple but too
abstract too detached from the actual
test they want to do and to make the
motivations very clear very obvious and
to drive the learning from the
perspective of the learner trying to do
something very specific like how do I
compete how do I beat my friend how do I
move my ships fast enough how do I do
this in a loop I really like this idea
it's something I'll be working on more
in 2018 I hope some of you might be
interested in contributing thank you
[Applause]